I wanted to talk a little bit about
about image filtering we had a video on
image filtering a while ago on Gaussian
blurs and mean blurs and this kind of
thing but remember we talked about
convolutions and convolutions are
actually used in a lot of places so
Sobel operator for edge detection but
also in deep networks so deep networks
have convolutions in as well so a huge
problem with something like a Gaussian
blur is let's suppose we want to do a
really big one right we want to do a
huge blur to really blow out an image so
you're talking about increasing the size
of the kernel that's right the radius of
the Gaussian and the size of the window
that we're sliding across is going to
get much much bigger suppose you want to
do is that even as even a relatively
small standard deviation you're going to
have a very very large window but you're
sliding across during your convolution
that's going to get slow really really
quickly let's remind ourselves very
briefly what a convolution is so let's
suppose you have an image which is
agreed I've always had bad luck drawing
grids in computer file videos they never
come out parallel I've seen what I mean
we have something called a kernel right
which is our filter that we're passing
over this image so let's say we've got a
very simple one which is our sobel
filter or Gaussian filter which is a
three by three now what we do on our
image has put a bounds on there we go
if we place this kernel over here over
the top three and we do a sum product so
we do the multiple of this one and this
one plus this one and this one plus this
one times this one plus this one times
this one plus this one times this one
and so on and now for a three by three
operator that's going to be pretty quick
right you can write this in C or
something like that it's gonna go really
really quickly and that's broadly
speaking what a deep network does just
doesn't lots and lots of times the
probabilities that suppose we want to do
like a big Gaussian blur or really large
window this is gonna get slow really
really quickly because to every position
in this image we're doing nine products
and then adding them all up if this
window is ten by ten or twenty by twenty
or a hundred by a hundred the amount of
operations per pixel is going to get
really quite large and we're talking
minutes to hours to just pass over this
image and yet the thing is if you go
into Photoshop or you go into an image
processing package and you perform a
really really large blur it doesn't take
minutes or hours right because that's
not acceptable it goes very very quickly
and so what they're doing really is
cheating right kind of what we're gonna
do is we
turn this kernel into an identical one
in two passes where we have a 1 by 3 and
then a 3 by 1 like that and what we're
saying is if we convolve our image first
by this one and then by this one we get
the exact same product as we would have
got if we just did it with the 3 by 3
and we've only used 6 values and that's
going to get better and better valar and
larger your kernel kernel goes okay
let's hang a minute right the first
thing to note is we can't just have any
you know n by n filter and decompose it
into 2 1 by n filters and it definitely
work right we have to make sure that the
process of doing horizontal followed by
vertical or vice versa is going to
perform the exact same operation as the
original combined filter and really this
is a simple matrix multiplication so
you've got a situation where you want
this matrix here however big it is to be
this one times by this one which means
that if you convolve any image with
these two you're actually doing it with
this right is easier isn't it on a short
of it now that isn't true of every
filter it's true of a Sobel you can
split Sobel up and it's true of
gaussians and it's true of mean box
blurs and so on but it's not true of any
kernel you wanted to use right which is
kind of relevant to deep learning but
but that's I'll mention that at the end
so how does this work well let's imagine
that we're convolving a pixel with this
horizontal blur right so we've got our
image which is going to be something
like this so you can also converting
fast Fourier transform so that's another
time right actually that is another time
because because that's really fast that
is that what it's called fast no all
right so let's imagine we're looking at
this pixel here now what we would
normally do is we'd sort of put our our
three by three kernel over here and we
do this sum product right but what we're
going to do first is the horizontal pass
so actually we're going to do it over
this one this pixel here is going to
include this one and it's going to
include this one like sometimes in
graphics they call this together in this
one and this one and this one and this
one but so this is going to be
calculated using these three pixels this
one is going to be calculated using
these three pixels this one's going to
be calculated using these three pixels
and that means that when we finally do
our vertical pass
here we're actually bringing this pixel
in here like this and what you can see
we've brought information from these
four pixels which we haven't our boys
done
we haven't actually looked at those
pixels with respect to here but actually
we've got that information and we've
saved a bit of time right if you've got
an n-by-n kernel and the number of
alterations you're going to need to do
for square kernel is going to be N
squared it's going to be 2n for a
vertical followed by a horizontal pass
I've coded this up and let's see how
much faster it is we need a computer
where did I put it I started writing
some Python code that I was gonna I'm
going to release the code right so I
tried to make it is you know simple as
possible so there were libraries in
Python to do this like OpenCV right and
they'll probably do it faster than my
code I wasn't really interested in how
fast it was apart from a comparison
right and I also wanted people to be
able to see how it works so what I've
done is I've implemented it in Python
but it was too slow because python is
not really suitable for you know
low-level pixel manipulations so what I
did was I then used syphon to compile
this python into C and that's much much
faster so if you want to look at the
code we'll put a link in the description
so essentially this is very very simple
we load an image up we turn it into a an
array and then we pass it off to siphon
which does a convolution with any kernel
that we provide and then returns a
response and at the moment what it's
doing is it's doing a 2d Gaussian blur
over quite a large image so I've got
this image but I took this morning of a
section of my Christmas tree so you know
that's looks like many other people's
Christmas trees it's a ball ball on it
too many bubbles actually and at the
moment it's relatively sharp right but
let's imagine we want to blur this image
I'm going to blur it with a two
dimensional Gaussian of size 10 - oh
that's a standard deviation of 10 the
radius is going to be somewhere around
60 pixels something like that like to
cover for the entire range of the
Gaussian so that's the one that now
so I've already compiled the Python into
C and the C into anyway so this is quite
a large image I think it's something
like 16 megapixels or 20 megapixels or
somewhere I don't know I'm running on
one of our servers
nobody really matters it's going to take
quite a long time because for every
pixel in our image we're looking at a 60
by 60 window right this is the long 2d
version
right which is why it's taking so long
in fact we might want to go and get a
coffee thank you
it's not dependent on what those pixels
eyes just it doesn't matter about what
the pixels are the operations per pixel
are the same obviously it matters a
little bit what the size of image is
it's still going I mean we could work
out roughly how many operations this has
to do but it's a lot I mean it's hard to
know exactly how many it does because
there are also bounds checks and things
like this not all the time but some of
the times so we could probably you say
at least this money yeah I still going
it's still a big it's muscle but yes it
is if our server yeah we're - cause it's
not motivated though GPUs would do this
really really quickly but you still
shouldn't be doing 2d convolutions like
this because it's incredibly slow so
it's four nine one two pixels by 3 2 6 4
3 2 6 4 which is 16 megapixels and for
each megapixel so for each pixel it's
going to do about 60 squared operations
so times 60 times 60
that's quite a lot of operations
actually see 37 billion and that's about
the bounce checking and we have a
business it has to do oh it's finished
it took 189 seconds is it looking person
well let's see it won't know it will be
I mean can you imagine you had to wait
this long to do anything in Photoshop it
would just be really bad news so let's
have a quick look at them here's my
output image and you can see we've
managed to obtain a slight blur like was
the standard deviation of 10 on the 16
megapixel image it's not actually that
much you're going to need to do a
standard deviation of into this sort of
dozens before you start to know some
real serious blur the complexity of this
problem is N squared even increasing the
standard deviation by a few more will
massively increase the amount of time it
takes so let's see if we can improve
things so I'm gonna I'm going to remove
that code and I'm going to instead run
it in two passes so instead of going
from the image to the output I go from
the original image I do an N by 1
convolution into an intermediate image
and then I convolve that with the
vertical version into the final image so
there's two convolutions but it won't
take double the time so let's run it
still pretty big image
so the original one took 189 seconds
eight seconds pretty good but eight
seconds is now into the point where you
could if as long as you had some
progress bar or something on app people
I'm gonna get too annoyed about it right
so let's let's increase the standard
deviation of this let's do it a little
bit more of an epic blur so forty five
in my code a kernel of standard
deviation 45 requires a window size or
kernel size of 271 so for every pixel it
would be doing 271 squared operations
new so let's just do a single 271 by one
and then a one by 271 all right so this
one that see how long it takes this will
take longer than eight seconds because
it's much bigger than ten but not a huge
amount longer right it goes up a little
bit within rather than squaring I'm
gonna guess all right so so quiz
I think 21 seconds okay I have no you
know I'm basing this on nothing but
random guesswork path seems plausible
yeah how long's it been now course you
don't know when is going to appeal my
screen I could go that took 36 seconds
so not too bad right that's a very large
if you look at the actual blur itself
I mean you can't see anything anymore
you know it just looks like my camera
work
I'm thinking today to my yeah for my
sins eggnog latte just once per year
otherwise just a special treat near the
end of the year